- Smells so good.
- I have a lurker.
(Henry vocalizing)
- [Hannah] You want to go to Vietnam?
- Yeah.
- [Hannah] This is a problem.
(yelps)
- [Hannah] 10 out of 10.
- Oh no, it's leaking!
(gasps)
- Oh, it's so good.
- This is unbelievable.
(pan sizzles)
- Oh!
(beep)
- Navajo fry bread.
- Forbidden cloud.
- Mmmm.
- [Hannah] This is delicious.
(blows kiss)
- Hi, I'm Hannah. I'm
the World's OK-est Mom,
and a while back I asked
my Instagram followers
to send me their favorite
recipes from all over the world
so that I could cook and
serve them to my family.
We had such a blast;
I got so many recipes,
and a lot of requests for
a Part 2, so here it is.
I can't wait to see what
countries we're going to visit,
culinarily, in my kitchen.
Wish me luck.
What are you doing?
(Henry vocalizes)
- I have vivid memories
of kids being teased
at the lunch table for the food
that they brought to school.
And that will not be my
kids doing the teasing.
I want to expose them to these foods,
so what better way to get started
than to cook it ourselves?
Now, I'm not an expert
at any of these cuisines,
so I had the wonderful help
of my Instagram followers,
sourcing recipes for me
that are super authentic to each area.
Now, some of these are family
recipes that I can't share,
but I'll link what I
have in the description,
and final warning: go get a snack!
This video is going to make you hungry!
- Hi Hannah, it's Crystal.
I would love for your
family to try my recipe
for thịt kho tàu.
It's sweet, it's savory, it's rich,
and it goes perfectly over white rice.
I hope you guys enjoy.
- Hi.
- Ooh, what's you making?
- [Hannah] Can you say
this with me? Thịt kho tàu.
- Thịt kho tàu.
- [Hannah] It's a
Vietnamese dish with rice.
- Viet-tamese.
- [Hannah] Vietnamese.
- Vietnamese.
- [Hannah] Yep.
- I have green onions, I
have garlic, fish sauce.
- Hi.
- [Hannah] All right, I've
got my marinade ready.
While the meat was marinating,
I made the dry caramel.
I'm going to put two tablespoons
of sugar in a dry pot.
You have to watch it very carefully,
because it can burn really quickly.
My kitchen smells
incredible at this point.
- Good, good.
- [Hannah] Excellent.
I think it looked gorgeous on the plate.
It was this golden, golden meat.
I couldn't wait to try this.
And I couldn't wait to
see what the kids thought.
What do you think, Jackson?
- It was worth the wait.
- [Hannah] The boys were in love.
- It's so good.
- [Matt] Is it?
(Hannah laughs)
- [Hannah] You look thrilled.
There were so many comments last time
saying Wyatt looked pissed
when he said he liked stuff.
What his body language
and expression is saying
isn't always what he means.
- [Matt] Resting Wyatt face.
(Hannah laughs)
- I'm very ready to try this.
Daaaaaang!
- [Matt] You sound proud about that.
- [Hannah] Mmmm!
Worth it.
What do you think?
- It's delicious.
- Oh, it's delicious this time!
- Yeah, it melts in your mouth.
- [Hannah] Mmmm!
- [Jackson] Mmm mmm so good!
- He has words today!
I sent a photo of the dish to my follower,
and she said that she would feed it
to her Vietnamese in-laws.
- [Jackson] Yeah.
- [Wyatt] I really want to go to Vietnam.
- [Matt] We should.
- [Hannah] You want to go to Vietnam?
- [Wyatt] Yeah.
- [Jackson] I want to eat all their food.
- [Hannah] To eat all their food.
Should I make this again?
- [Jackson] Yes yes yes yes yes.
- [Hannah] Yeah.
- [Matt] Yes.
- [Hannah] We love it.
- Hi Hannah, this is Jennifer,
and I would love for you and your family
to try some traditional Haitian recipes
for griot, pikliz, and bannann,
or what you would call fried plantains.
- Time to make some Haitian cuisine!
Griot is a citrus-marinated pork
that's then either baked or fried.
I prepped the pork the
day before; I diced it
and then I marinated it
in all this lovely citrus.
And now I'm prepping my pikliz.
There wasn't the tri-color cabbage,
so I'm just using the plain cabbage.
So I'm going to cover this
and let it marinate for about two hours.
All right, I'm cooking this
pork for about 30 minutes.
I feel like after the last
week of food around the world,
I got a lot more comfortable with frying,
so I felt very ready
to fry these plantains.
I don't know if I'm supposed
to stand them up like this.
My house was smelling amazing.
Combined with the pork
marinated in all this citrus,
it was just a lot of good
smells going in my house.
I'm going to test smashing
one of the plantains.
I'm going to try some foil and a pan.
Oh! There we go. I think that worked.
Now I'm going to dip it in
my water, salt, and vinegar,
and then I'm going to re-fry it.
I have a lurker.
- [Matt] It smells good in here.
- Smells good, looks good.
- Mmm, looks good, smells
good. It is good. Thank you.
- Well, we'll see if I do a good job.
- I can't wait.
- [Hannah] I thought this
plate looked magnificent.
- That's fried bananas?
- [Hannah] Basically.
- How do we eat this?
- [Hannah] With your fingers.
Now the boys were a little confused
when I served them and we
didn't have any silverware.
And that's why it was so important for me
to serve it the way
that it's usually eaten
so that when they see someone
eating with their hands,
they can think to themselves,
"Oh, I've eaten with my hands,
and I know that certain
foods are meant to be eaten
with your hands."
- [Matt] Mmmm.
- [Hannah] Mmmm.
Oh my gosh.
I was surprised, especially,
about the pikliz,
because the flavor is pretty sharp,
and the kids loved them,
and they were just piling
them onto their pork
and asking for more.
What do we rate this?
- [Matt] 10 out of 10.
- [Jackson] 10 out of 10.
- [Hannah] 10 out of 10.
(cartoonish twanging)
(laughing)
You know, when my kids
are excited about food,
that comes out as total silliness,
so it was a really silly
(laughing)
and fun night, everyone was in a good mood
because everyone was eating good food.
- [Hannah] You want more pikliz?
(Henry vocalizes)
- [Wyatt] Pikliz, pikliz, pikliz.
I'm making something tonight
that I think the kids are
going to freak out over
and I'm very excited to make.
I'm making Navajo fry bread tonight,
which is basically
(dish clanks)
whoa, shh, geez, Oh my god.
I dropped my flour.
Now frybread is a dish that's served
in many Indigenous
cultures, not just Navajo.
So there are many different variations
and lots of different recipes.
The recipe that I was given
had two different ways to serve it;
one was kind of a taco,
and one was a little more
sweet, with a berry jam on top.
So I'm going to do the sweet one.
I did order one thing special,
because my follower said that
it has to be Blue Bird flour.
This flour comes in a sack.
So we're just going to
drizzle it with a little oil,
and cover it for two hours.
Smells so good.
I want to just take a bite.
What is this forbidden cloud?
Now, the sauce I'm going
to make for this fry bread
is called wojapi.
It's just berries and water.
I'll get this really thin.
Are you in here snooping?
- Yeah.
- [Hannah] I think it's a little too thin.
We'll do the next one a little thicker.
That's looking beautiful.
I think I finally got the hang of this.
When it was done, it
looked like this beautiful,
puffy, bread loaf, with that
gorgeous berry sauce on top.
The boys were in heaven.
In heaven eating this.
- Mmm.
- Who gave this the right
to be this delicious?
Look at how fluffy it is inside!
- That's really good.
- 10 out of 10.
- [Jackson] 10 out of 10.
- 10 out of 10. 11 out of 10.
We'll be making this again.
- Hey Hannah, it's your friend Jasmine.
I'd love for you and your
family to try my recipes
for Korean tofu, cucumber
salad, and braised potatoes.
They're some of my
favorite Korean side dishes
called banchans.
They are packed with
flavor, very garlicky,
so good luck on the breath. (laughs)
But they're worth it, I swear.
Hope you like it.
- [Hannah] Hello again. It's me,
prepping my Korean food.
Of course I'm going to make
something that Jasmine suggests!
She makes the most
delicious, beautiful food.
I'm going to prep the tofu
and the cucumbers tonight.
I got my cucumbers drying over here.
I sprinkled them with salt.
I'm going to chop my green onion
and get the rest of my marinade together.
- Hi.
- [Hannah] We have our tofu marinade.
I pan fried the tofu first
to get it nice and crispy,
then I reduced my marinade
a little bit in a pan,
added the tofu back in,
and then put that all in a container
to chill in the fridge overnight.
And let's move on to our cucumber.
(cucumber rattles)
Okay, we gotta let these
marinate overnight.
You know, he's here,
he's supposed to help me,
he's been sitting on this
stool the whole time.
Matt has it pretty easy when
it comes to food in this house.
But just you wait. He will get his.
To finish out our Korean meal,
I have my potato peeler so
kindly peeling potatoes for me.
So this Korean potato
recipe is very simple.
It was just soy sauce,
and honey and garlic.
I added a little bit more
honey and sesame seeds after.
When I put everything
together on the plate,
it looked like my dream meal.
It's like all the little bites.
- [Jackson] Mmm. I love it.
- [Hannah] Yummy.
I even bought the spoons
that I saw Jasmine using.
- [Wyatt] Mmm.
- These potatoes are incredible.
Moment of truth Matt, try the tofu.
- I already went through one piece.
- Oh, you did? Did you like it?
- [Matt] Mm-hmm.
- My family always gives
me grief when I make tofu.
They really liked it.
Everybody loved this food.
I don't think we'll have any leftovers.
We are one happy family today.
- Hi Hannah, I'm Grace.
- And I'm D'Vante.
- And we want to share a recipe
for Bahamian guava duff with you.
- What you'll find is
that this dessert recipe
is something that's used
in many different Bahamian households.
Enjoy!
- Here are my guava preserves.
A dollar? A deal!
A guava duff is a sweet,
fruit-filled cake-ish roll
that's boiled instead of baked.
So I cut in a bunch of shortening,
and then I added some
baking powder and salt.
So I'm nervous about this;
I don't know how thin I'm
supposed to roll this dough out.
I also had to roll it out
with a bottle of wine,
because I don't have a rolling pin.
I'm going to do a good amount.
Oh geez, okay. Did I do this right?
When I went to roll it up,
I think I had rolled the
dough a little too thick,
so all of my guava was spilling out
and just getting smushed by
the heaviness of this loaf.
Now I'm supposed to seal the ends.
Oh gosh, I have just a handful of jam.
Got this all wrapped up in its blanket.
So the boiling aspect
of this duff, I think,
keeps it really, really --
I don't want to say this word --
M-O-I-S-T,
and makes it more of a pudding-y cake
instead of a dry cake.
It was really the moment of truth,
when I unrolled it,
to see if all of my guava had spilled out,
so when I unrolled it,
it looked pretty good.
I was shocked.
I really hope I get that
spiral in the middle.
(gasps)
Ooh. Oh no, it's leaking!
Why did I do this?
Oh (beep). Okay.
The spiral needed a little work.
I have some rum cream sauce on here.
(Wyatt gasps)
- [Jackson] What is that?
- [Hannah] Ooh it's dessert!
I gave it to the boys, and
their minds were blown.
- [Both] Mmm.
(Hannah laughs)
- [Jackson] Tastes like apple pie.
- [Hannah] Do you like it?
- [Jackson] Mm-hmm.
- [Wyatt] Uh-huh.
- [Jackson] Love it.
- [Hannah] It's like a fluffier
apple pie, though, right?
10 out of 10?
(gasps)
Wow!
It's like if pie crust and
cinnamon rolls had a baby.
I've never had a pastry like this.
This is delicious.
(singing) Going to Peru
tonight for dinner.
We made green arroz con pollo.
It is a chicken and rice dish
that's all cooked in one pot
with this amazing green sauce.
(sniffs) Mmm, that smells so good.
I started out by browning the chicken.
That chicken looks nice.
In the chicken drippings,
I'm going to toast the rice.
I added the green sauce
and stock to my rice
(pan sizzles) Oh (beep)
Oh my god, okay, that heat's too hot.
Okay, that was very intense.
I laid the chicken on top and
then you just let it cook.
When I finally pulled it out,
it was beautifully green,
the chicken looked super juicy,
and the rice looked really
fluffy and delicious.
Everybody loved this dish.
Even Henry loved this dish.
Henry actually got to eat this for dinner.
You like it?
(Henry vocalizes)
- [Hannah] Yeah.
- [Matt] This is probably
my favorite, I think.
- [Hannah] Really?
- [Matt] Yeah.
- [Hannah] It's always a good day
when everyone enjoys the food.
This dish was really easy;
I could see it becoming a
staple recipe in our house.
Wow.
It's so flavorful.
- [Hannah] Thumbs up?
- [Matt] Oh, yeah.
- We're making mofongo tonight.
Mofongo is a dish made of plantains
and crispy pork skins which
are also called chicharrones.
It's typically served with a stew
or it can be stuffed with
meat or stuffed with food,
but it's all compacted
into a little mound.
I'm back with the plantains.
I did fry them and I really
feel like that's my calling now.
Jackson now thinks he's a vlogger,
so he kind of took over
the filming for this one.
- She's all the way
over there in her room,
so that means I can secretly dance.
- Watch out, I have a sharp knife.
(Jackson gasps)
So I'm going to mash the
plantains with these pork skins,
crispy pork skins, and some garlic.
I packed it all in a bowl,
and then went to flip it to take it out,
and that's where I met a roadblock.
Oh, no.
(gasps) I'm stuck.
Oh, there we go.
It looked incredible, it smelled amazing,
I plated it with a beef stew
because it looked hearty
and it looked like it
would go along with it,
and I could not wait to
see the boys' reactions.
- [Jackson] Mmm, mmm, mmm. So good.
- They loved it.
I think Jackson probably
loved it most of all.
He was slurping it up.
Wyatt wouldn't use a fork or anything
to get the mofongo off the dome.
Wyatt is just -- he is who he is,
and we love him for it, and that's it.
Oh my gosh, I can demolish this
whole thing in two seconds.
This is delicious.
- Oh my god.
- [Hannah] 10 out of 10?
- 10 out of 10.
- [Hannah] What do you think, honey?
(Henry vocalizes)
You want more?
I will definitely be making this again.
It's really easy to find ingredients,
it's easy to make,
and the kids really enjoyed it.
- [Jackson] Puerto Rico
knows what they're doing.
- I feel like we hit the jackpot.
These dishes now go in
my Rolodex of recipes
that I want to make forever.
And I want to keep doing this,
because I think it's a really
important learning experience
for teaching them
about appreciating other cultures
and appreciating other foods
and smells and textures
and ways of eating.
So I want to also thank all of you
for sending me your recipes.
I wish I could document them all,
but I am certainly making them all.
My kids and I are so
appreciative and grateful
to have these special dishes in our house.
So that's all for now.
I'm Hannah, and tell
me what country's food
we should try next.
Please link me some recipes
and please let me know
if you'd like to see a Part 3 of this.
Now if you'll please excuse me,
Henry and I have some cuddles to do.
Did you like the food?
'Til next time.
(bouncy plucky music)